[Music]
we're gonna do a little dyslexia on
stage tonight so hopefully it'll be
something historic for the Latin
community
[Music]
Luis FONSI and daddy yankee spiced up
the 2018 Grammy Awards performing their
global smash this bus seat though lots
of dancers lights smoke the works but
noticeably absent Justin Bieber who's
featured on the hit songs remix is
Justin gonna join you on stage he's not
he's not you know he's been very
supportive of the song obviously you
know he's been a huge part of the puzzle
he's not here he's recording his album I
spoke to him yesterday and he's super
excited hopefully you know you'll see us
all together on stage one day
[Music]
what does it feel like to have the
biggest song of the year it's you know
it's the stuff you dream up you know and
I was a little kid this is what I dreamt
this is why I've worked so hard you know
20 years in the business and finally
this song comes along and I get you know
to work with amazing people and and
there it is we broke the language
barrier and everybody's dancing and
singing and we're all united and that's
what music should be about